ja
ich habe mitgebracht ein zitat des
chinesischen außenministers yang he
natürlich sehr beschäftigt ist das mal
im wortlaut vor damit ich nicht falsch
zitieren china und russland sind
füreinander die wichtigsten
geografischen nachbarn sagt er und
strategischen partner die beziehung der
beiden völker ist felsenfest und folgt
der logik der geschichte china und
russland während ihren werden ihren
fokus nicht aus den augen verlieren wir
bilden eine partnerschaft zur
koordinierung einer neuen ära
und genau darum geht es hier natürlich
ganz ganz maßgeblich putin könnte das
gar nicht machen ohne chinesische
rückendeckung und es ist eine frage des
hegemonial strebens ist bedauerlich dass
es dass nach wie vor so gibt aber was
mich umtreibt ist der eindruck dass die
hegemonie des alten westens unter
führung der eu der usa
vorübergeht vielleicht ist sie bereits
vorüber gegangen mit dem 24 toten
russland agiert nicht alleine russland
agiert mit voller unterstützung chinas
und dass dieser eingriff es jetzt
erfolgte hat mit den olympischen spielen
in beijing zu tun wenn die nicht gewesen
wären wäre der mensch wahrscheinlich
früher erfolgt und das etwas was mir
große sorge macht weil ich nicht unter
einer hegemonialmacht china und auch
nicht russland nehmen möchte
also ich glaube dass
uns diese krise eben auch gezeigt hat
dass in dieser welt in der autoritäre
staaten zu kooperieren sich den rücken
stärken auch bei ihrer aggressiven
außenpolitik ihren ansprüchen
unterstützen dass sie in dieser welt
organisationen eben wie die europäische
union den letzten jahren sehr oft sehr
naiv agiert hat sich die aber in dieser
krise jetzt
zum ersten mal seit langem wieder
entdeckt was für eine existenzielle
sicherheit dadurch entsteht dass die
beiden eben nicht alleine sind dass
polen eben nicht alleine ist dass die
europäer bei sanktionen als
wirtschaftsmacht ein land wie russland
auch wirklich treffen können wir kennen
jetzt dass diese europäische union und
der alte westen wo wir glück haben das
jetzt nicht donald trump im weißen haus
sitzt in dieser krise
ein rückgrat sind dafür dass das europa
die demokratie die menschenrechte die
freiheit die wir als gegeben genau
hingenommen haben verteidigt werden
können also ich glaube was wir jetzt
auch erkennen ist wie gefährlich es war
in den letzten jahren und wladimir putin
hat ja auch hinein investiert
er hat der parteien und politiker
unterstützt die anti europäisch die für
den austritt aus der europäischen union
waren wie frau le pen in frankreich bei
den letzten wahlen die wie matteo
salvini die europäische union als ein
neues imperium angegriffen haben
matthäus halt wie nie war vor wenigen
der beliebteste politiker italiens und
sagt er fühlt sich in kreml wohl und
nicht in brüssel
diese diese politik putins das zu
schwächen was uns jetzt in der krise
letztlich vor noch mehr ungeschützt wo
wir jetzt unsere verteidigung stärken
müssen wir müssen die europäische union
auch die beistands verpflichtungen die
sich aus dem eu vertrag ergeben das muss
substanz annehmen dass wir nicht auf
alle ewigkeiten vollkommen abhängig
bleiben von der frage wen wählen die
amerikaner aber ich glaube genau das vor
dem bild das sie skizzieren mit
autoritären herausforderern die
aggressiv sind ist der zusammenhalt des
westens die institutionen die wir haben
umso wichtiger und ich glaube das wird
jetzt hoffentlich auch in deutschland
weit über die das einfach für gegeben
hin da sehen sie dass putin sich sich
geirrt hat putin dachten nämlich hier
könnte das alles weiter spalten und
auseinander treiben und das exakte
gegenteil ist eingetroffen also ich
arbeite in brüssel ich erlebt dass jeden
tag die eu steht in diesen tagen seit
kriegsbeginn so geschlossen wie ich sie
nicht erlebt habe seit seit ich dort
arbeite und das immerhin ist ein
hoffnungszeichen nicht viel mehr als das
weil wenn sie den vertreter der
europäischen union als gesprächspartner
nehmen dann agiert er bis heute nicht
auf augenhöhe
das sind die amerikaner und die russen
eventuell noch immer kommen aber
sicherlich nicht der boris
hinter mir gehört paul ja also ich
ertrage ich ertrage das einfach nicht
wenn er morgen über die geschlossenheit
der europäischen union spricht er tut so
als wären sie ermorden für eine
geschlossenheit der europäischen union
noch einmal sie haben die sanktionen
hinter trieb sie haben gesagt die
sanktionen müssen enden in einer zeit in
der wladimir putin bereits hier frauen
und kinder umgebracht hat indem er den
tombers mit waffen ausgestattet hat mit
kämpfern ausgestattet hat indem er diese
menschen motiviert hat und auch
russische kämpfer rhein geschickt hat
die ukraine anzugreifen das war der
anfang dieses krieges der gerade hier wo
ich bin stattfindet und sie haben gesagt
diese sanktionen müssen aufhören und
jetzt reden sie allen ernstes über eine
geschlossenheit der europäischen union
die sie gut finden wo sie immer gegen
diese geschlossenheit agiert haben und
sie haben als ard vorsitzender und als
der herr wollten als der sitzen sonst
werden sie doch gar nicht in irgend
einer tv show noch wenn sie nicht wie
vorsitzender gewesen wären also
entschuldigen sie bitte mal das kriegen
sie auch nicht aber das kriegen sie auch
nicht von dieser da sind sie so und in
dieser funktion waren sie im
europaparlament und da haben sie in
verschiedenen in ganz vielen
verschiedenen funktionen gesagt diese
sanktionen sind falsch und sie haben
dafür gesorgt dass dieser europäische
union gespalten ist dass europa
gespalten werden konnte das war der
anfang des endes der ukraine und das
haben sie mit zu verantworten nein nein
für uns aber ich muss das wirklich
wirklich zurückweisen das ging und geht
auch jetzt noch darum dass man in einen
konstruktiven dialog hinein findet und
das geht nicht auf dem weg der vom
westen beschritten wurde im übrigen hat
war ich immer ein
kritiker der vielen politikfelder die in
brüssel falsch angesiedelt sind ich habe
aber immer ein ausdrückliches bekenntnis
zur europäischen union am tag gelegt das
war für mich übrigens einer der
zentralen gründe aber sich gegen diese
ich heute an die brechungen und die
europäische union das ist doch erneuten
sie waren als fdp vorsitzender ich kann
jetzt mehrere mitteilungen vorlesen in
sehen sie sich dafür ausgesprochen haben
dass die sanktionen beendet werden und
jetzt tun sie so als wären sie für die
sanktion das ist eine glatte lüge nein
stopp stopp also einer lüge lass ich
mich nicht sein ich habe gesagt jetzigen
sanktionen halte ich für richtig
die sanktionen die wir vorher hatten
habe ich für falsch gehalten da hätte
ich auch dialog gesetz in der jetzigen
situation der krieg im osten war nicht
so schlimm oder was die genossen war
nicht so schlimm im donbass wenn da
frauen und kinder gestorben sind da
haben sie gesagt dass es nicht so
schlimm hat es im tief da muss es
sanktionen geben herunter mir sie habe
eine sehr eigentümliche sicht auf die
ereignisse im don was das müsste man in
einer lang habe ich eigentlich gar nicht
da habe ich nicht nur sie ein recht
durchsichtiger diese lernten die sendung
ist lang genug erneuten die sendung ist
lang genug um um zu entlarven und ihr da
schon aber ich gehe ganz christian ganz
kurz ja heißt mehr einholen der hatte
bislang die wenigsten redezeit mehr als
alles gut also ich finde das ja an
interessanten und auch ein wertvollen
dialog soll sogar zweimal ja wirklich
schön dass auch mal auf zeigt wieder
agiert wird mit halbwahrheiten und
herunter man hat ja zum glück wirklich
die redaktion kenntnis vor ort um das
auch widerlegen zu können und es ist
natürlich der punkt den herr klaus auch
zurecht angesprochen hat ist diese
naivität die auch zu lange bei uns im
westen noch vorgeherrscht hat und man
merkt ja auch nach wie vor also ich hab
das erwähnt wenn die alv den
bundestagsabgeordneten hat wo der kreml
sinngemäß sagt den haben wir der tasche
aber leider erleben wir es auch bei der
linkspartei wo eine führende
außenpolitikerin sagt also der der
ukrainische botschafter in deutschland
sei ein hetzer vor dem herrn ja nicht
etwa putin das ist so eine art fünfte
kolonne der autokraten sagen so will er
endlich ganz eine sehr politische macht
die wfg und weise wie wir uns zu sagen
von merkel eisenstein weisenau ihrer
synagoge herrlich reiter ist wirklich
nicht zu überbieten sie geben jetzt hier
den geläuterten weil sie auch nach
crailsheim man sonst nicht weiter ich
wollte mir selber noch davon dass dies
vorher kräftig verlassen was er ja das
ist ja richtig aber sie kommen das ist
ein habe diese theorie nicht haben
wollten noch gesagt es ist also nicht
einmal ein putin gemacht hätte fehler
waren sehen dass dort fehlt mir noch
semantische ungenauigkeit sie habe
fehler und er hat kriegsverbrecher in
syrien unterstützt der hat
völkerrechtswidrig land in europa wieder
eines ihrer jugend hieß er hat gute
kriege geführt so dass sie nicht
irgendwelche fehler das sind
kriegsverbrechen zum teil ja und das ist
genau diese diese perfide vorhaben
lösung in den formulierungen die werde
erleben wenn sie frau verschenkt ist bin
vorgeworfen haben das war kein spin das
hat er uns haben uns doch eben erklären
das war eben die wahrheit